a local chef is helping those in need
this holiday season
chef a gogo ron sims opened a pop-up
restaurant at the boulevard mall today
with the help from a few community
partners the location will pass out food
and christmas gifts to those who need
them
sim says he wants to share his own
success after pulling his way out of a
life of poverty
while living on the east coast this is
just something great to be a part of
this is a part of our brand this is what
we want to do we want to give back
you know to the community i live here i
work here
and i can't think of any better way to
give back to the city of las vegas
that has given so much to me with the
clark county school district being
closed
there's a lot of kids out here in the
vegas valley who are not eating
a good meal you know and so today we
want to provide some hope
some served up orange chicken with rice
and veggies along with some dessert
it was all in pre-packaged containers to
keep everyone safe sounds delicious